hey everybody welcome back to streaming
took a couple days off got a lot of
concerned messages from people on Friday
David where are you yesterday Saturday
Trump is you know propagandizing at you
know a dock somewhere because the ships
going somewhere where are you I took two
days off from streaming it was a mental
health break the press conferences have
become increasingly propagandized
in essence and Donald Trump now going
full propaganda you might have noticed
in the last few he didn't even talk
about the death toll the case numbers
it's all about you know exciting new
products that will be popular with
coronavirus customers and he's getting
great ratings during the press
conferences and we'll get to some of
those tweets in a little bit so I'm back
I've been the last couple hours I've
been starting to work on in research
stories for tomorrow's show got my
groceries I'm ready I'm back to
streaming and we are going to be hearing
maybe in four minutes maybe in 40 in 34
minutes maybe in 64 minutes from Donald
Trump initially today was scheduled for
5:30 Eastern then it was Trump tweeted
it's at 5:00 Eastern which is in just a
few minutes but they always start late
anyway we don't really know what time
they're going to start today but I have
plenty of stuff to go through with you
and I'm gonna be thanking people I will
answer super chats from people watching
on YouTube remember to Like and
subscribe as you come in so a few things
to look at the official numbers now have
grown beyond 700,000 official
coronavirus cases it seems like only a
few days ago it was 400,000 and that's
because it was and we have just a rapid
rapid increase you will see that today
so far we have nearly 10 percent growth
in new cases in one day alone and it's
still early 55,000 new cases the u.s.
number 1 now in in total cases and
number 1 in active cases and every
expectation that these numbers will
continue increasing more and more
rapidly at least until April 14th and
that's a date that we're increasingly
looking at has nothing to do with
Trump's Easter delusion we'll talk about
that a little bit
let's go down and take a look actually
let's look at case statistics as you can
see here actually in fact let's look at
death statistics because cases can be
under measured as you can see we now
have I guess if you go back to March
13th to 14th we had a slight reduction
in the number of deaths but essentially
increasing all the way since February
26th and yesterday 3,500 worldwide
global deaths and today we are so far at
3000 and still you know many many hours
here until the numbers reset in the
United States we are now at a hundred
and let's just refresh okay we just
picked up 200 cases in the last minute
we are now at a hundred and thirty nine
thousand official cases of twenty four
forty five deaths yesterday we had a
whole bunch of deaths I think the number
was five hundred something and then we
will see where we are today by the end
of the day we are increasingly hearing
from the president that you know states
with a couple hundred cases only which
are very few by the way you've got to go
to Wyoming which has no nobody lives in
Wyoming statistically you've got to go
there to get to these small numbers but
as you can see even Nebraska has more
than a ten percent increase today and
what you have to look at the growth
rates even places with few cases are
going to start growing quickly
you know Kansas nearly a twenty percent
growth today Iowa is at ten percent so
very quickly a hundred cases becomes a
thousand and that's what we're seeing
very entry I'm gonna get to all of the
different stuff and people chatting with
me momentarily a very important website
that I encourage people to check out
this is co vid 19.8 org this is an
estimator of when are we going to peak
and right now peak resource use okay
this doesn't mean peak in cases or
deaths but peak resource use meaning
beds and ICUs and ventilators needed is
expected to be April 14 now I want to
talk about this April 14 number a little
bit just as a you know little shortcut
New York started earlier the rise
started earlier so New Yor
is expected to peak on April 6
Massachusetts started earlier than lots
of places but not that early so we're
expected to peak on April 12 what does
this mean because people are saying we
just got to get to April 14th and then
we're good no first of all the peak can
last a week or longer if you look for
example at like Italy as an example
Italy has arguably peaked but they've
been peaked all the way back to March 20
it's been nine days at this peak level
the peak can last seven days 10 days
whatever so even if we peak on April
14th that doesn't mean on April 18th
were on the decline and very importantly
if the decline is as long as the ascent
if it took us six weeks to get to the
peak it could take six weeks to go down
so understand that if we peak in 15 days
we're 30 days from getting back to a day
like today and today is not a good day
so this is relatively optimistic and it
still suggests that we're in this for
the very very long haul so that's the
big picture you know catching everybody
up since I was away for a couple days
from streaming I wasn't traveling around
or anything
I was watching Tiger King and and you
know that sort of thing that is what
that that is what we are now looking at
now by the way speaking of Tiger King
we are memeing very very hard right now
on our on our u2 on our Twitter page and
everywhere else so there's a lot of meme
edits you can participate in this is me
holding a friend's baby we are accepting
edits of this and I encourage you to
send them to me david at david
pakman.com but we also have some
mattress related memes this is did
somebody just say Tiger king and me
doing a very I was not thrown somebody
believed I could only get that high if I
was tossed but I was not tossed I jumped
there under my own power and anyway you
can tell things are getting ugly as a
result of the self quarantine but
there's that and then I had another
mattress related one that I posted
earlier this weekend let me see if I can
find it here where is it here oh no
that's not oh yeah so I posted this
people started turning it into other
things but then we're all here it is
as me before the Trump press conferences
so anyway I'm doing what I can to spread
the you know but I wouldn't exactly call
it cheer but we're trying to just do
something other than just bring you
absolutely horrible information okay let
me start by thanking Henrik Steen who is
new member number one today at join
pakman.com so I was able to fortunately
tell you guys last week that we've
totally decentralized all david pakman
production everybody's working from home
and you know that bit that's a good
thing and we started to see a little bit
of a trickle down that's not even the
right word we've started to see a little
bit of a decrease in YouTube revenue
that is now down close to 40% sadly
because YouTube's revenue is based on
advertisers bidding up the price of ads
fewer advertisers are in the game so
we're actually suffering Bigley on
YouTube right now which is why we're
doing a lot of these streams because the
folks who sign up on my website or who
send super chats or get twitch
subscriptions or whatever we're
basically just trying to not lose that
much revenue during this so I really
appreciate everybody who's been getting
memberships excuse me that's just me
choking not that's not that's not the
corona at join pakman.com really
appreciate it because it is we we've
been you know it the YouTube revenue has
just been brutal
we estimate down about 40 percent so I
will continue to enthusiastically thank
everybody who signs up let me do some
twitch thank-yous here okay indubitable
Questlove has subscribed Crimson Elric
is now a 7-month subscriber plague of
the earth is just gifting subscriptions
left and right which I very much
appreciate that is egregious has sent a
few bits our way and Neptune 99 has
subscribed now for two months two months
at Tier one very much appreciated let me
get to some super chats and of course if
you're joining us on youtube remember to
hit both like and subscribe like and
subscribe is big it's huge these days
Donna William says welcome back David
hopefully Trump's its this one out he's
worthless yeah check out this clip of
Trump from an over the weekend press
conference listen to this pandemic
pandemic by this disease this whatever
they want to call you've got it germ you
can call it a flu you can call it a
virus you can call it many different
names I'm not sure anybody even knows
what it is right so this was not six
months ago this was 48 hours ago Trump
still says does anybody even know what
we're dealing with yes we do we're
dealing with a corona virus this is
kovat 19 these have been studied for a
very long time these are transmitted via
droplet typically people's coughs and
sneezes sometimes through surfaces as
people pick it up it is a respiratory
illness it is not treatable with with
antibiotics as it is not a it is not a
bacterial look we know this stuff and
Trump's still talking about do we know
any we don't know is this a germ is this
a flu no it's not so the press briefings
have gotten very very ugly let me by the
way I'm just looking for it we always
want to have a couple streams waiting so
here's the White House stream we've got
that and I just want to check real quick
if we have if any if any stream goes
live for example I think that sometimes
Washington Post let me see Washington
Post YouTube coronavirus sometimes they
have we like to see what's going on in
the room whenever possible let's see if
well oh I found I found the Washington
Post feed so we're gonna take a look at
that and see where that kind of gets us
see if we've got a live feed oh this one
is this is outdoors that's interesting
live at 5:00 p.m. from coronavirus task
force at the White House Wow okay so
they it looks like they may be doing
this one outdoors great well in any case
we're waiting for it we are here and we
are waiting so we're not going to miss a
moment of this idiocy don't worry about
it at all
okay Danny Thompson says I'm a member
but throwing this $10 at you for looking
out for yourself taking mental health
time welcome back yeah you should see
the stack of books that I am getting
through and it was really it was a good
thing to take a couple days off from the
streams we're back and
you know plan to be here all week of
course people don't seem to be
distancing in this live video either
everything that's going on is just a
mess Charlie says David small tech note
when you end YouTube streams they seem
to end abruptly before you actually
finish it's probably only a few seconds
but wanted to point it out not sure if
others see this as well thanks so what I
usually do is when I stop talking I'll
put on this screen
now I don't know if when I do that it's
still cutting off my audio in some weird
way but I've been doing that lately to
try to try to prevent that problem I
don't know if that I don't know if that
works or if it doesn't work but I'm
gonna keep doing my best guys I'm gonna
keep doing my best let me say thank you
to Matt Marciniak who is new member
number two today at join pakman.com
thanks Matt very much appreciated also
moreton ID is new member number 3 today
at join pakman.com let's see here Krispy
Kreme says you should definitely do
Trump bingo during one of the streams
yeah so if we did Trump bingo we would
have tremendous nobody's ever seen this
before who could have guessed China we
were handed something bad by the
previous administration what else what
else would be masks ventilators Deborah
Deborah is probably it mentioned her
Mandela mints the fake news media I
actually picked up three elements of
medical over the weekend and when I
called my dad and said what have you
guys been up to whatever what I
mentioned I had picked up elements of
medical he was shocked I was even able
to find them at this point in time but
we are in Boston we do still have
certain elements available okay let's
see Michael Ewan says considering most
college students and large portion of
adults don't qualify for the stimulus
checks do you think Congress will offer
help I I was talking to friends about
this on a zoom hangout yesterday and we
don't we don't know we don't know it's
it's an excellent question we just don't
have answers to a lot of these questions
well let's see friendly-fire says please
google interactive chart a Koosh kovat
trends at tissue kovin trends let me see
here I took Ovid Trends let's see here
oh okay yeah I've seen this well I'm not
gonna put this website out yet because I
want to review it fully but I've
somebody sent me that and I that is very
interesting
let me say thank you to Hara ranga or
hero Rangga who subscribed on twitch the
noble walrus thank you for the second
month subscription Ruby whisper obscure
link and Bionic Pope are all all
participating which is very very much
appreciated I also want to say thank you
to urban Cordova who is new member
number four today at join pakman.com and
Jeffery Hughes who is new member number
five sad news sadly because of
coronavirus one of our two actually of
our gear manufacturers have shut down so
unfortunately we're probably gonna have
to just take down our online store
because we're not able to get the items
to people because some of our vendors
have shut down completely so I will be
issuing refunds to folk sadly it's
another revenue loss source which is
very very much unfortunate but you'll
either get your items for people who
ordered like the data mail t-shirts and
stuff it's isn't this just depressing
like everything is just shutting down
but yeah we're gonna we're gonna do the
best we can to get that restarted at our
earliest convenience
let's see Steven okay I want to get the
last the name correct because I got it
wrong last time where to go
Steven Spano Dacus geez I hope that's
correct world ometer x' dot in for yes I
the world ometer world ah meters website
is the one I've been consulting for a
lot of a lot of this data so to speak
and sadly it looked like maybe Italy had
turned the corner and then deaths
actually peaking over the last two days
it's been almost a month of this in in
Italy extremely extremely tragic
essential says I keep getting into
debates in your tweet comments
oh I don't so I advise you just don't
even do it
Sara Giuliani Sara Giuliani is a YouTube
member elements of medical says for the
effort thanks for all you do David
thanks to Henrik Steen for signing up on
YouTube Jeremy Landry says people still
like Trump despite his clear failures so
yes that's true tomorrow though there we
you know when when we had some first
initial approval polls for Trump it was
like wow fifty five percent or something
say he's handling the virus well we are
go we now have new data where Trump's
approval rating has drastically fallen
it seems as though it was a bit of a
honeymoon you know rally around the
president sort of thing early and it
seems to have very much reversed very
very much reverse so we'll talk about
that tomorrow let's see here I don't
read you know people who want me to just
attack other youtubers I don't read
those cacus Umbra says Trump flu ends at
twenty twenty Jammu oma wale great to
see you a Jawa John was been on a lot of
the streams what a way to spend my 40th
birthday smoking a fat one while
watching David yeh lockdown yeah it's
it's bad it's my little sister's
birthday today she's she baked the
brownies with a friend over FaceTime you
know I mean this is what we are this is
what were relegated to but alas you know
what somebody told me something over the
weekend that I found in a completely
vapid way inspirational which was these
things have a beginning a middle and an
end
and we're definitely right now at the
start of the middle and take that for
take that for whatever it is we are
definitely now in the middle of it still
the build-up at some point we will be on
the back end of the middle and maybe
someday we will be at the end like every
day we're a day closer to the end I
don't know I'm trying this is not
exactly I don't know that this is
inspiring that many people let's
actually let's cut that all out of the
stored video for this stream because
it's actually very depressing
Ginobili says thoughts on Biden sexual
assault allegations
I have not commented on that yet because
we've not done a broadcast show yet but
keep an eye on the show this week doctor
rain says my temporal scanner has been
cheap quarantine entertainment you just
pointed and Wow it takes your
temperature fascinating yeah you like
Trump recently recently finding out I
guess
about infrared scanners Kyle V says why
tweet the periscope link YouTube stream
so we are live on Twitter and Twitter's
live functionality is is comes from
periscope so to the hundred people
watching on Twitter right now that is
that is why that's the way it's going
let me say thank you to Nick Jepsen
whose new member number six today at
join pakman.com also want to say thanks
to Aaron Hopkinson whose new member
number seven as well as I think I missed
one person here hold on Marvin Howard is
new member number eight I really it's I
really sincerely appreciate the people
signing up for memberships YouTube ad
revenues down almost 40% because of the
virus everybody's tightening their belts
of folks are canceling memberships I I
get it I get all of it
so everybody who is supporting I really
do appreciate it and on that note jh8 CS
has subscribed for seven months with
twitch prime okay I had a couple other
videos I wanted to show you okay we
talked about this one already oh okay so
I'm increasingly convinced that Trump
has a bit of a Jesus complex with the
entire Easter stuff we the Easter thing
Trump you know Easter for people who
believe in this stuff and this is not me
you know but for people who believe in
this stuff Easter is the commemoration
of the resurrection of Jesus Christ I
think and tell me I'm wrong if that's
the case because I don't know what damn
thing about about it but Trump in a way
clearly has this god complex where he
wants to miraculously reopen the country
he wants to resurrect the country on
Easter
so when Trump talks about Easter it's
not just a random day Trump imagines in
his sick head which is functioning more
and more poorly with every passing day
he imagines the country deifying him as
the resurrector as a sort of god-like
figure on Easter remember this is him
talking to Bill hammer on Fox News about
it but Ortolan is never going to be like
being there so I think Easter Sunday and
you
have packed churches all over our
country I think would be a beautiful
time and it's just about the time line
that I think is right it gives us more
chance to work on what we're doing and
I'm not sure that's gonna be the day but
I would love to aim it right at Easter
Sunday so we're open for church service
and services generally on Easter Sunday
so anyway that's a God Delusion that he
has he wants to be deified and yes I
understand that he's delusional in more
ways than just this one way I totally
get that but that's don't don't
underestimate that as a factor here and
of course Trump I don't believe that
Trump is religious he was never
religious he claimed to be religious now
you know 2 Corinthians and all of this
stuff and the Bible is as good as art of
the deal because he needed to be because
he was running as a Republican that's
that's that's essentially the reality at
this point in time let me say thank you
to Violette Honfleur Violette on Fleur
is new member number 9 today at join
pakman.com very much appreciate the
support thank you so much okay
other super chats continue to come in
khaled Hawass lee says david i'm a
member but my comments keep getting
deleted not sure why i don't feel i said
anything inappropriate are there any
rules we should go by LOL call it i
don't know anything about that but
remember all too the moderators we want
to take a light touch we don't ban
people for disagreeing we don't ban
people just for like you know insulting
politicians we don't ban people for
being republican we just are gonna ban
people for just persistent spamming like
putting the same message over and over
and over again in the chat you know hate
speech anti-semitism and word stuff
anti-semitic stuff directed at me or
others homophobia you know personal
attacks that's at you I think we're
gonna have a relatively light touch
disagreement and even even edgy content
is fine we don't want to be banning
anything any of that stuff thanks to
everybody who is just joining me on
YouTube I do want to ask you a very
small favor please hit that like button
and also hit the subscribe button
we very much appreciate both we should
be I mean we've got like 5,000 people
watching on YouTube we should be able to
get to at least 2,500 like
one would imagine one would imagine and
the the subscriber counts are doing okay
we actually actually were only 300
subscribers from 820,000 that which is
crazy I assume there's lots of non
subscribers here 4,700 people watching
yeah make it remember like and subscribe
is a big thing and if you're watching on
Twitch hit that follow button thanks to
you guys we did surpass 32,000 followers
during the last the last stream which is
exciting JR says I read this morning
that trumps approval has gone up how is
this remotely possible yes that happened
last week the latest data that I've
gotten suggests a big reversal and that
people are realizing the death toll is
partially partially driven by Donald
Trump partially everybody's dealing with
this but we have had close to the worst
federal response Carlos says who do you
think is better frogs or dinosaurs it's
good question you know I think probably
frogs yeah I feel I feel very strongly
about that Phil H says David supposing
the world's most persuasive man
convinces Biden to step aside and
endorsed Bernie what happens next guys
that I mean we're not gonna deal in
fantasy HS dte says what exactly do you
mean when you say elements of medical I
understand English is a second language
but we usually tend to be more specific
you know what that phrase you're right
English is my second language but it's
not Donald Trump's second language and
this is where it came from okay from a
man whose only language is English
[Music]
that's where it comes from
I understand listen despite English
being my second language I understand
that elements of medical makes no sense
but ask the guy who came up with the
phrase which is which who is Donald
Trump see what he met by elements of
medical Cardinals 100 says he needs a
medical amount of water to prepare
unknown prodigy says they are lying to
homeless in Philadelphia saying they are
not eligible for stimulus checks and it
will be taken to pay for services look
into this okay I will look into that Tom
Oh Wayne says UK press video calling in
at the press conferences UK press video
calling in at the press conference I are
you saying that now the UK press
conference is the the nobody's there in
person people are calling in that makes
sense actually thanks to Michelle why
Splott Dane for signing up on YouTube
Robert Xavier Betancourt jr. sends a
super chat Armando Salazar says thanks
for keeping us informed during these
tragic times
Diana Kayson and Tom st. Denis have
grabbed memberships des says thank you
for covering this David it's good to
hear someone with a level head like
yourself comment yeah if you're just
joining us I didn't do the Friday press
conference and I didn't do yesterday's
Gong Show sending off the hospital ship
I just took a couple days off and I
tried to follow the news as little as
possible obviously it's impossible
because every time I do a zoom thing
with friends of mine or whatever
everybody's talking about this but I did
I did a lot of reading went on a very
long bike ride yesterday at a socially
appropriate distance with a friend were
a full hazmat suit during the bike ride
and everything and I'm back I'm back now
and we we are resuming we are resuming
the entire thing let me say thank you to
Ralphie face for subscribing with Prime
on twitch little England subscribes and
says happy to support you David
independent media is more important now
than ever
that's my feeling that's my feeling
Randy MP has subscribed with prime score
'but has subscribed with prime if you
were just joining me I do have some
various meme contests happening on on on
my twitter twitter yes twitter at des
Pakman this is me now this is what I do
before every Trump press conference
so some people are liking that I also
have a meme contest going where I held a
friend's baby and submissions are being
accepted at david at david pakman.com
this is me holding baby trump which is
pretty good I actually like that quite a
bit and we may even be able to integrate
some of these elements of visual into
future David Pakman show stuff and then
I don't know if anybody's been watching
that Tiger King but anytime anybody
brings it up this is this is what I do I
just jump right into place and I'm ready
to watch it there you go
just right in boom by the way somebody
keeps telling me that
whoever's wheezing probably has
coronavirus that was just my girlfriend
trying to be quiet to not be on video
and she was suppressing a laugh she's
not wheezing at this point in time no
wheezing no Corona thank you okay let me
say thank you to a few new members Diego
Crespo is new member number 10 today
at join pakman.com now here I'm gonna
make an executive decision here
Catherine McCray already had a
membership but she has upgraded the
membership from two to four dollars a
month to became four I'm counting it
okay Catherine is counting with an
upgraded membership as new member number
eleven today at join pakman.com very
much appreciate it coupon code 2020 now
you save 66 percent and we are dealing
with a 40 percent drop just like a body
slam of 40 percent drop of YouTube
revenue unfortunately because of the
virus and a lot of advertisers not
advertising anymore on YouTube so the
streams are really helping us to recover
some of that some some of that lost
revenue so I do appreciate everybody
who's been signing up okay
Alexander Jones says David to what
extent is the regressive left real it
exists and it is pretty it's allowed but
very small slice of the left adam
Waddington says April 12th is obviously
not realistic but how soon do you think
we should plan on some kind of
restrictions reopening of certain
businesses so
here's my view on this right now and
again I am NOT a medical expert as many
of you know my my formal training is not
is in economics not medicine but here's
my sort of take on it
the best estimates right now are that
peak resource use is going to come on
April 14 okay so let me give you what I
think is reasonable at this point in
time if peak resource use comes on April
14th and last seven days okay that
suggests to me that somewhere around you
know April 21st or so we are going to
start seeing a decline if that is if
we're 15 days from that 15 days after
April 21 we would be back to sort of
like we are today that would be like May
6th I think think we need two more weeks
past that so my belief is that on May
20th and I this the sucks I hate that
this is the reality right but this is my
thought May 20th we would probably be in
a condition where in non hotspot areas
that we're starting to see a drastic
decline young people maybe people who
have recovered and are by every
indication are immune those are folks
who could start to help to reopen the
economy we would still have to keep
older folks and people were at risk
pretty well protected that's my thought
right now okay May 20th would would be
something now what does May 20th look
like here May 20th
right okay so May 20th as you can see
you know every every decision has risks
and trade-offs economic and and health
and right now any reopening is going to
drastically increase the death toll
that's where I am right now I know a lot
of people are saying it differs by
location yes that's true but there's
also this idea like if you have a
hundred cases you don't need to do
anything well maybe but a hundred cases
becomes a thousand cases and not that
long if you don't do anything so it's
complicated very very complicated let me
say thank you to Jay Reisinger Jay
Reisinger is new member number 12 today
at join pakman.com I also want to say
thing
- Ralph Cruz who is new member number 13
today at join pakman.com really
appreciate your support very very much
Parker Winans oh hold on a second
where'd that go where is it
Parker Winans where was that part
there's Christians going to church on
Easter will be bad yes it very will be a
disaster it will be a disaster I would
expect an explosion you know a lot of
the kind of hippie lefty churches here
in Massachusetts simply say they have
messages like believe in God and stay
home you know or God is watching stay
home stuff like that being realistic
about the entire thing and saying stayed
stay the hell home essentially that's
what we need Andrew F says have you
heard of Argentinian dr. Alfredo Moreau
Lee discussed yes I watched that video
and it's an interesting one Marty pomper
Meyer met pumper Maher has subscribed on
YouTube
Tom st. Denis has longtime freeloader hi
from Canada eh thanks Tom
Okoye yo Madrid has subscribed on
YouTube Charlie says Trump's ratings
tweet today is that his low point yeah I
have it here I was waiting for someone
to bring it up so listen to the delusion
of Donald Trump Trump tweeted today
because the ratings of my news
conferences are so high bachelor finale
Monday Night Football type numbers the
lamestream media is going crazy
Trump is reaching to many people we must
stop him said One lunatic see you at
5:00 p.m. by the way we're 28 minutes
past that true oh by the way check out
my wrist oh my goodness my response
actually got a bunch of people liking it
I responded you're suffering none that
mental illness and personality disorders
get help turn over control of the
country to someone else please people
are dying you know that's so funny I
just randomly saw that 400 people like
that
so Trump thinks people are watching
these press conferences because they're
popular like a reality show
people are watching because over time
more and more people are staying the
hell home and
more and more people are seeing the
death toll rack up and they're desperate
to hear something that you would call
leadership from the president they're
not watching because their ratings
they're not watching because this is fun
or because this is what people want to
be doing the level of delusion that is
required to tweet something like this is
absolutely it's off the charts it's off
the charts and dr. Justin Frank a
psychiatrist who we interviewed recently
said that every of every one of his
proteges he didn't say it every I'm
telling you every one of dr. Justin
Frank's predictions about how Trump
would behave in a real crisis as a
result of what Justin Frank has
identified as Trump's mental state is
happening and I won't give you the full
list but definitely definitely check
that out and consider liking my response
to Donald Trump here on this tweet I'm
shocked actually that this many people
even saw it's weird usually that doesn't
happen when I when I respond to to Trump
okay
sometimes by the way I will go to a
Trump tweet and I'll tweet just as a
just to see if the sycophants will come
out of the woodwork like like like opium
being released from a poppy I don't know
if you've seen video of that but it just
oozes out sometimes I'll see if the the
trumpets will ooze out of Twitter to
praise me I'll go to a Trump tweet and
I'll say something like Thank You mr.
president for your courageous you know
like I'll pretend to be a complete
lunatic like half the country is and all
sorts of trumpets start retweeting me
and loving it and saying look at David
of course a couple people will actually
click on my profile and realize that
it's merely trolling me you're merely
merely trolling nothing nothing but
trolling let me say thank you to Dori
Martin Dorey is new member number
fourteen today at join pakman.com Daniel
boudin is new member number 15 today
thank you so much Daniel very much
appreciate that and everybody's support
at join pakman.com yes people asking
this was scheduled for 5 p.m. Eastern
that's 30 minutes ago if you look at
Trump's schedule it's actually double
listed at 5:30 and 5 p.m. and then now
at this point you know who
knows when it's actually going to start
it seems to be getting a sort of a
little grim there in Washington DC
outside the White House but reporters
sitting very very close together and you
know nobody's nobody's social distancing
it's a mess if you're just joining me on
YouTube we are standing by for what have
now become the daily delusional rantings
of Donald Trump oh also I think Trump
might have had dr. Burks lobotomized I
it really pains me to say this but dr.
Burks she did an interview the other day
with the Christian Broadcasting Network
she said that she that Donald Trump is
using data and and not analyzing the
facts I'm gonna try to find the video
here for you I don't know what happened
to dr. Burks but it's either some severe
form of Stockholm Syndrome or she may
have been lobotomized by Trump take a
listen to this insanity scribe the job
president Trump is doing behind the
scenes and in front of the cameras
during these daily briefings that we're
seeing what's been your perspective dr.
Burks
he's been so attentive to the scientific
literature and the details and the data
Trump's attentive to the scientific
details and the data okay meanwhile 48
hours ago Donald Trump said this
pandemic by this disease this whatever
they want to call you caught a germ you
can call it a flu you can call it a
virus you can call it many different
names I'm not sure anybody even knows
what it is how does a guy who is paying
attention to the scientific literature
and the data after three months of this
say we don't even know what this is is
this a flu is this a germ is it a virus
dr. Burks has been lobotomized and we
simply can't listen to her anymore
I think his his ability to analyze it
integrate data that comes out of his
long history and business analyzed and
in she sounds like she's talking about
you know you've all her re not not not
Donald Trump has really been a real
benefit during these discussions about
medical issues because in the end data
is data and he understands the
importance of I I you know I can't even
watch the entire thing
because this is oh man I think you guys
know I think I don't even really have to
say it you guys know what's going on
it's it's disgusting okay Stephen Hart
says God imagine if he's sick and that's
why Trump's late yeah every time he's
late people start suggesting that's
what's going on not so far
beetle Greg says hey David what's your
favorite Canadian province you know I
know it's Quebec and I know I'm gonna
get I'm probably gonna lose half of my
Canadian membership but Montreal is one
of my favorite places in the Northeast
area and it's it's Quebec you know what
can I say the bagel shops the delis the
restaurants the the old port the the
museum's it's it's Quebec that I'm sorry
okay
Helen Alderson has grabbed the YouTube
subscription name withheld says what
exactly are they preparing they never
have any information other than made up
facts also today
foul chi or foutch no yes my new term is
I'm an authoritarian foul gist so far
but foul she may still jump the shark
don't you know if Burks was able to be
LaMotte lobotomized foul she may also
say czar marin says I have kovat 19 he
are ruled out influenza A and B and
rhinovirus 10 days in waiting for
results chest pain intense breathing
worse they are taking forever in Arizona
I'm sorry to hear that sis out and it is
not a rare story but you know stay as
healthy as possible and and hope to see
you recovered in a few days marika says
you don't have to be religious to do
traditional Easter stuff food
decorations sometimes even churchy stuff
has value as a cultural experience like
listening to Bach even as an atheist
well that that is all true Marika but
Donald Trump still seems to have a God
Delusion
when it comes to why he wants churches
reopened on Easter let me say thank you
to Peter Luke dur is it Peter Luke tur
Peter Luke tur new member number 16
today at join pakman.com Nathaniel young
is new member number 17 today at join
pakman.com
also want to say thanks to Michelle
Royce whose new member number 18 at join
pakman.com Judith zimba roof is new
member number 19 today Daniel Hendricks
is new member number 20 thank you so
much for the support we it we've been
struggling with with everything going on
and I really do appreciate it also want
to say thank you to oh no that's it I'm
caught up okay very good
couple more chairs being brought out
here by Oh apparently they're gonna
really fill this thing up they want they
want it more full okay so a lot a lot
happening here as we stand by Wow very
weird very very weird what's going on
let me ask everybody watching on YouTube
to do me just a tiny favor please do hit
that like button as well as the
subscribe button this stuff it's free
and it so helps our streams which helps
us generate a little more revenue in
this difficult time make sure to do that
and if you're watching on android on
your phone you have to X out the live
chat to see the like and subscribe
buttons they are by default they are
covered by the live chat just a quick
quick note let me say them some Twitter
thank-yous let's see here
do you grok has subscribed with prime of
course i grok grok of course coming from
the great book stranger in a strange
land by Robert Heinlein I remember it's
weird sometimes when you read a book you
remember where you were when you read it
and I remember I read that book during a
trip to Mexico in 2011 a stranger in a
strange land by Robert Heinlein
excellent book I don't care about
Highland Heinlein being a conservative I
know okay I don't care
excellent excellent book and I do grok
which sort of me my understanding of
gerak is you sort of implicitly
understand you kind of get you get it
dead Zed's also has subscribed with
prime be Ren Romero has subscribed on
Twitch Raphael Bartol Otto is also a new
twit twitch prime subscriber and so is
Bob Bob
21:02 thanks Bob appreciate it super
chats continue to come in as we stand
to buy for Donald Trump and laying out a
bunch more chairs
reporters sitting very close to each
other is this possibly six feet right
here it looks like 14 inches to me that
looks like about 14 inches this maybe is
2 feet between these two guys well it's
not looking good
it's very very not looking you're not
looking good also this chair is a fire
hazard right here that really shouldn't
be there but I wouldn't be surprised to
see Kaitlyn Collins from CNN sit there
again and Trump call on everybody other
than her that's been his thing lately
okay
Nabil Kaveri hey Nabil Nabil has been a
fixture on my streams thanks for the
work David you being yourself is enough
for some of us to believe in a brighter
future what an inspiring message keep
moving forward and I'll get your back
thank you
Nabil that's one of the nicest things
anybody's ever said on stream I really
appreciate that
Jack Dixon says hey David my job
department of defense contractor with
2,000 employees in New Jersey has two
confirmed cases so far we are still
coming in on a regular schedule
irresponsible irresponsible is right
absolutely
Nathan C says could you compare
long-term death rate trends versus
current ones I keep coming across people
who still seem to think this is not much
to worry about I don't know what you
mean by that
long-term death rate trends versus
current ones uh I don't know that I'm I
know what you mean the rate of death
increase in the US has been higher than
in most other I'm sorry the the rate of
case increase has been higher than in
most other countries but I don't know
that I'm exactly sure what what you mean
Justin stole and Mark send super chats
dara h says research veganism please
there is no way to justify the slaughter
of animals in today's society be it
morally environmentally or nutritionally
Stephanie Wagoner grabs a subscription
John Henley says is Trump actually busy
or is he being fashionably late
I read that Trump made a trump delayed
his phone call with the Chinese
president by 90 minutes to do a Fox News
interview so it wouldn't surprise me
that he
is you know that he's just hanging out
waiting for the ratings to build so to
speak which is disgusting and
embarrassing okay let me say thanks to a
few other folks here okay hold on a
second okay Sasha Calloway is new member
number 21 today Thank You Sasha
appreciate it Earvin Cordova has
upgraded his subscription so we'll count
him as number 22 Eric Gonzalez is new
member number 23 today at join
pakman.com Susan Curlin is new member
number 24 today Stephan Boehner is new
member number 25 let's go for fifty why
not let's keep it going
fifty is better than 25 Clayton Sackett
is new member number 26 today beautiful
love it
join pakman.com is the place and you
know what I'm just gonna throw something
else here Alai levy has grabbed has
started contributing on patreon I'm
gonna count it I'm gonna count it we're
counting patreon contributions
patreon.com slash david pakman show
we're gonna count them towards fifty
because why the hell not right okay
let's see here invisible scourge and I
like that says spooky it is looking
spooky in Washington DC
the weather is is weird there yeah
nothing no live video yet on all these
other spots so we'll see how much longer
we have let's see what's happening with
the PBS stream same thing okay it looks
like it's the exact same feed oh no the
PBS one is a half second ahead let's
stick with that I want to bring you guys
the stream the the press conference as
quickly as possible and the PBS stream
is about a half second ahead ok lickin
s'en let Lycan s'en lichens n' says
please keep informing in these dark
times
I hope the death rate doesn't reach its
Hallion level I doubt it though I have
no idea at this point what to expect a
Brian Mack says sing baby shark in your
head
but replace the words with baby Trump
here's a c-note for your shows thanks
Brian appreciate that
Walker Anderson says believe all women
quickly became ignore Tara Reid
Joseph Hugh says thanks for being good
stuff
Safari J says I'm seeing a lot of
criticism from progressives directed at
AOC Bernie etc for not organizing to
improve the bailout bill and voting for
it what are your thoughts let's uh let's
see everybody seems to be filing out now
we see my oh I think they're gonna be
sitting rather than standing this is
Mike Pence here they're bringing out the
cavalry here's the lobotomized dr. Burks
we see Anthony foutch II other people I
don't really recognize but it looks like
everybody's going to be coming out soon
a lot of this is gonna be a prepare
yourself this is gonna be a clown show
let me say thanks to Scott Thompson
whose new member number 28 today thanks
Scott really appreciate you signing up
at join pakman.com no social distancing
happening here certainly not six feet
between these folks they did get that
middle chair out of the aisle though
which is something Mark Davis says my
grandparents keep going out all the time
in Pennsylvania they watch fox news and
love Trump it's sad I mean you know one
of the things is if the people behaving
irresponsibly were the only we're only
putting themselves at risk we could at
least make it some kind of like worry
about yourself thing but it's contagion
one other thought on that I keep hearing
people talking about you know now a very
very popular thing
Jordan Belfort the wolf of Wall Street
who I interviewed recently and you know
whole bunch of people are saying look at
how many people die of car accidents
look at how many people died of
second-hand smoke look at how many
people died of the flu none of those
things are increasing at the
out-of-control rate that coronavirus is
increasing and number two the flu is
transmitted virally but car accidents
don't spread virally it's not a
contagion thing it's one of the dumbest
comparisons all right here's Trump with
siga listen
prepare yourselves thank you very much
thank you
[Music]
extra orange today appreciate everybody
being here beautiful day in the Rose
Garden tremendous distance between
chairs ly social distancing you practice
it very well we appreciate it that's
great let's just see if it's louder here
and well we appreciate it that's great
a little louder yeah I want to start
today by highlighting several critical
developments on both the testing and
treatment that will help us win our war
against the corrupt it is lo let me just
see if any of these are louder
distancing you practice it very well we
very she ate it that's great I want to
start today by highlighting several
critical developments on both the
testing and treatment that will help us
win our war against the corona virus on
Friday the FDA authorized the new test
developed by Abbott Labs that delivers
lightning-fast results in as little as 5
minutes that's a whole new ballgame
I want to thank Abbott Labs for the
incredible work they've done they've
been working around the clock
normally this approval process from the
FDA would take ten months and even
longer but we did it in four weeks
Abbott has stated that they will begin
delivering 50,000 tests each day
starting this week and as you know even
before this development we've been doing
more test tests than any other country
anywhere in the world it's one of the
reasons that we have more cases than
other countries because we've been
testing it's also one of the reasons
that the last about the lowest in terms
of mortality rate because we've been
doing more testing so we have bigger
numbers to look at light I want to also
thank General Semin I'd of the Army
Corps of Engineers and general Paul of a
Czech who's here with us is going to say
a few words in a little while risky
pronunciation what the Army Corps of
Engineers did
along with FEMA in New York was
incredible they built two thousand nine
hundred beds worth of hospital an
incredible hospital in the Javits Center
which I know well and I just want to say
that was unreal they did it in less than
four days people have never seen
anything like that and it's Binga an
incredible complex top-of-the-line
hospital they did it so quickly
everyone's trying to figure out how they
did it including me and I was a good
builder but they did it very quickly
Mike so we're very we're very happy so I
want to thank Army Corps of Engineers
FEMA the incredible job they have done
now they're moving to other locations
throughout the country where they
already have people building hospitals
who are doing them in Louisiana and New
Jersey many many other places but these
are incredible men and women and they
worked around the clock and the people
of New York are very happy Governor
Cuomo expressed his thanks which we
appreciate
right but these are I mean this nobody
could have done a job like that most
people have never seen anything like it
the deployment of rapid testing will
vastly accelerate our ability to monitor
track contain and ultimately defeat the
virus we will defeat the virus the
invisible also allow us to test doctors
nurses and other health care workers
immediately and enable us to act quickly
and aggressively to shut down the spread
of the virus so important in critical
facilities like hospitals and nursing
homes and we will ensure that we can
give cities and states the best
information to guide local decision
makers and making I want to point out
that the hydroxy chloroquine is being
administered to 1,100 patients people in
New York along with the z-pak which is a
zero Meissen right and
it's very early yet it's only hit
started two days ago but we will see
what happens
I want to thank Stephen Hahn who's a
great notice everything everything it
supposedly was starting on Monday and it
started two days ago which was Friday
like everything is just a lie we don't
know
well Hospital in Texas and he's the head
of the FDA and Stephen got approval for
that so fast let's see how it works it
may it may not but we may have some
incredible results we're gonna know soon
so it's tested it's being tested on
1,100 people in New York the FDA is also
allowing the emergency use of a blood
related therapy called convalescent
plasma yes as an experimental treatment
for seriously ill patients that his
interest his treatment involves taking
blood plasma from patients who have
already recovered from the virus so they
recovered they're strong something was
good in them that worked something was
good and so we take the plasma from
those people that have recovered so well
meaning their plasma is rich and
antibodies against the virus and
transfusing it into six patients six
patients very very very powerfully so
sick patients will be transfused with
the the blood taken to boost their
immune system we'll see what happens
anda blabbing some early results that
are good but we will see and that's
going I think very rapidly again we got
approvals and really very quick time
we're also looking at an approval for
the sterilization of masks I kept saying
to myself I'd see some of the masks are
very complex we're delivering millions
by the way millions but I kept saying
why aren't they able to use that mask a
second third fourth time and Mike DeWine
the great governor of Ohio called me
they have a company that is in the final
process of getting approval for the
sterilization of masks and in some cases
depending on the mask some of these
massive Eric
very strong powerful very strong
material they're able to power sterilize
the mask up to 20 times so that's I
guess like getting twenty masks and not
reason we worked in that as soon as I
heard from Mike today he's not quite
like got involved and the FDA is now
involved and we're trying to get a fast
approval for the sterilization of masks
that would be a tremendous difference
would be really helpful well much of the
research has to be done we have a lot of
research left to do obviously this
treatment on plasma plasma has shown
promising results in other countries
were in communication with other
countries and very strong communications
and they're very reliant on us in just
about all cases we have the greatest
people in the world they're very very
anxious to find out how we're doing on
our different things whether it's a cure
or whether it's really anything having
to do with getting people better we have
some interesting things will be
announced I think over the next few
weeks but we'll see what happens they're
being tested right now the vaccines are
moving along very rapidly the mex
vaccines are 12 days a month so an
answer but I'd like to see if we could
do something therapeutically so that we
could take care of the people that are
already sick and we're working on that
at a level that people would be amazed
these incredible people they don't stop
this method also has been used for more
than a century and that's the blood
related therapy more than a century to
fight off infectious diseases so it's
not unusual our level of complexity has
changed but it's a concept that's been
used for a long time including during
the Spanish flu epidemic and that was
really a pandemic of proportions like
frankly nobody's seen until what we're
facing now that was in 1918 you know
what the result of that was probably
from 75 to 100 million people
were killed and also other viruses like
the one in this out outbreak this is a
very tough one this is a tough one
because it spreads so quickly like
nothing we've seen it spread so easily
so quickly we're unleashing every tool
in our nation's vast arsenal economic
metal metal if you look identical
scientific military Homeland Security is
working very very hard with all of them
in order to vanquish the virus as you
know every level of government state
local and federal is working non-stop to
obtain more personal protective
equipment for frontline workers we're
delivering vast orders of this material
I'm going to ask a couple of the people
here he sounds like he's struggling more
than usual to read his own notes right
joining us today are the leaders of
America's largest distributors of
pharmaceuticals and medical equipment
including McKesson Cardinal Health Henry
Schein Owens and minor MEDLINE FedEx and
UPS we just concluded a very productive
meeting about ways to keep our supply
chains and delivery systems moving at
top speed and maybe I'd like to just ask
for a couple of minutes from Mike
Kaufman to come up and maybe Edie Paseka
his favorite for for-profit CEOs to just
come up and praise them but I and I
appreciate and if anybody else has
anything please come up but if you could
come up Mike for a second and Ed for a
second just you could maybe say what you
told me before when we had the meeting
thank you Thank You mr. president and
thanks for your leadership on this
because of that leadership we have
really seen the government agencies
working with industry like no time
before we've seen HHS FEMA the CDC work
incredibly effectively with all of the
distributors and all of distributors
working together for the good of the
people and all of us have been so
focused on making sure that we take care
of our customers because we our
customers
are the ones that are taking care of the
patients every day we need to do
everything we can to make things good
for them and so it's been great to see
how well all these government agencies
have been coordinating together with us
thank you thank you I don't think that's
what Trump wanted him to say that was a
very exciting or mr. president let me
first start by thanking administration
for all the support you've provided to
the industry you know one of the things
we did we did here the challenge and
starting in January we've ramped up our
production in the Americas including our
facility in North Carolina where we are
now manufacturing an additional 40 to 50
million masks per month to get into the
US healthcare system we talked a lot
about this in the pre meeting one of the
issues were struggling with is the
demand increase you know used an
anecdotal example of one Hospital in New
York that traditionally uses roughly 10
to 20,000 masks a week are now using 2
to 300,000 mass a week so you multiply
that times the entire puppy's entire us
let alone the same demand outside of the
US that's part of the issue we're
running into is even with a significant
ramp up in supply those are crazy still
that demand that is that is much greater
than that supply and I bring that up
because it's we have a CEO come up and
just simply say like demand is up so
we've got to work on increasing supply
like this is where the priest is that is
this how they talk to him behind the
scenes like is that the level that they
have to talk to him about that
they've been delivering for years 10 to
20,000 masks ok it's a New York Hospital
very it's packed all the time how do you
go from 10 to 20 to 300,000 10 to 20,000
masks to 300,000 even though this is
different
something's going on yes the control
came to it as reporters we're the
masculine are they going out the back
door they're being used to 300-thousand
and we have that in a lot of different
places so somebody should probably look
into that because I just don't see from
a practical standpoint how that's
possible to go from that to that and we
have that happening in numerous places
every that extent the virus number I've
heard that
highest number you've seen I would
imagine right but this man makes them
and delivers them to a lot of hospitals
he knows the system better than anybody
and I think you were more surprised than
I was when you saw that number so thank
you hope I didn't get any of your
clients in trouble but it could be that
they are in trouble there you have to
look at that in New York FEMA is working
with these companies to launch somebody
largest airbridge please expedite the
movement of critical supplies from other
countries to the United States the first
flight arrived at JFK Airport New York
this morning filled with 80 tons of
personal protective equipment including
130,000 n95 respirators those are the
ones that we were talking about before
1.8 million face masks and gowns 10.3
million gloves and many other things
millions and millions of different items
FEMA has scheduled 19 additional flights
and is adding more daily we hope to have
about 50 flights we're going to have I
think including the one that came in
today we're up at 51 flights with these
massive planes from the different
companies that were so nice to be here
today would you like to say something on
behalf please come up yes thank you
[Music]
thank you mr. president for the
incredible leadership Oh share with you
that UPS is really proud to be part of
this effort vice president pence and I
had the opportunity to speak before and
the way we're gonna win this war is with
great logistics and UPS is gonna be part
of that effort we have a big brown army
495,000 ups across the country that are
ready to deliver we're bringing in the
supplies from anywhere around the world
as fast as we can so that they can serve
the communities that need them most
we're proud to be partnering with the
states as well because we know that in
partnership with those states we can
deliver what is needed everywhere so
Thank You mr. president
please thank you very much
Thank You mr. president I would
certainly like to echo my colleagues
comments that the collaboration amongst
many of the government agencies and the
private market the distributors
represented here today has been
incredible has been increasing and
ramping up over the past weeks
today's first delivery of operation air
bridge I think is the first evidence
that it's working the 51 flights you
referenced we're excited about we look
to build upon that so I would echo my
thanks for your leadership and certainly
to the staffs for the terrific
partnership and the commitment to
protect the people we think about most
often which are the people on the front
lines providing care and maybe just a
quick word of thanks on behalf of all
the CEOs here to our teams that continue
to show up in warehouses across the
country in pharmacies across the country
and do their jobs to keep the supply
chain going the supply chain is working
it's resilient supply as a challenge
we're tackling that
[Music]
weird press conference guys thank you
Thank You mr. president
and thanks to FEMA and HHS I think great
leadership and its really working well
the demand has skyrocketed and we're
doing a lot of things to bring in more
mass more other protective apparel we
are involved in reprocessing masks and
we've already started about a hundred
thousand mass per day and we hope to
expand from there so we're quite
optimistic about it yeah thank you yes
please maybe a doctor could speak one
that hasn't been lobotomized by trial
thanks thank you Thank You mr. president
we appreciate the opportunity to work
with your administration on a lot of
collaborative fronts number one we've
all talked about PE products that's
critical and it's not just at the
hospitals that's a must but it's really
to all healthcare providers out there
working on the front line so our
commitment is there to get it to the hot
spots and get it to the care providers
that are taking care of those patients
it's absolutely key second we talked in
there about buying in America and
getting resources back here in
manufacturing in America that is
critical a lesson to be learned from
where we are and lastly we're proud that
we introduced a test we need to get some
more tests out there and a rapid form
we're excited about that we've worked
with your administration very closely in
the FDA and we're very grateful for that
because it's a Rick quick rapid antibody
test that need as well so we're really
proud to work with your administration
all going well thanks so much thank you
so thank you all very much and for the
great job you're doing it's really
incredible frankly many of the states
are stocked up some of them don't admit
it but they have we have sent just so
much so many things to them and what an
embarrassment including ventilators you
know there's a question as to hoarding a
ventilator some hospitals and
independent hospitals and some hospital
chains as we call them they are holding
ventilators they don't want to let them
up we need them for certain areas where
there's big problems can't hold them if
they think there might be a problem
weeks down the road no that's how you
need to say well we've delivered a lot
and this group has been really fantastic
we want to thank you and UPS and FedEx
particularly you've gone absolutely out
of your way so so we appreciate
everything you've done and delivered the
federal government continues to mobilize
every resource to make sure frontline
doctors and nurses have the equipment
needed to save American lives yesterday
I visited Naval Station Norfolk as the
USNS comfort departed for New York three
weeks ahead of schedule fully loaded
with 12 operating rooms 1,000 hospital
beds and hundreds of the best doctors
nurses and medical professionals
anywhere in the United States Navy
anywhere frankly in the United States it
was an incredible thing to see a mostly
you saw that on television as it was
leaving it left literally three weeks
earlier it was under maintenance and
they got the maintenance done very
quickly they work around the clock as
many of the people have and it was a
great sight additionally two of the
country's largest health insurers Yamada
and Cigna are announcing that they will
waive co-pays which is a big deal for
anybody that understands insurance they
don't waive co-pays too easily but we've
asked them to do it and they've done it
coinsurance and deductibles for the
coronavirus treatments to help when he
announced that three weeks ago and it
wasn't true he's announcing it again
today
endemic so they're waiving co-pays
coinsurance and deductibles nobody's
I don't think anyone's heard of that one
of you heard of that one before I
haven't heard I want to thank them great
companies today I spoke with Wolfgang
Puck Wolfgang Puck is a great restaurant
tour as you know as is Jean George and
Thomas Keller and Danielle Balu and
other leaders in the restaurant business
which has been probably one of the
hardest hit industries I have directed
my staff to use any and all authority
available to give restaurants bars clubs
incentives to stay open you're gonna
lose all these restaurants and they're
not gonna make it back and they have to
get going that's true so what I'm doing
is I'm going to tell secretary minuchin
and also our great Secretary of Labor
who you know very well to immediately
start looking into the restoring of
deductibility of meals and entertainment
costs for corporations that set the
restaurant business back a lot when it
was done originally and then done not so
long ago so we're going to is for the
most part as a business expense meals
and entertainment are only 50 50 percent
deductible if I spend a hundred bucks on
a business meal I can only deduct fifty
of it as the business expense Trump's
ideas bump that back up to a hundred
percent if he even understands what he's
talking about I'm assuming he does that
may be a mistake and we want to make
sure they do so we're going to look at
the restoration restoring the
deductibility of meals and entertainment
cost for corporations so the
corporation's can send people to
restaurants and take a deduction on it
like they did in the old days that was
when restaurants were doing really well
the financial relief bill I signed on
Friday provided historic relief for
American workers and small businesses
and includes three hundred and fifty
billion dollars in job restoration and
retention so if you look at job
retention loans for small businesses
that's a big deal with loan forgiveness
available for businesses that continue
paying the workers so it's 350 billion
job retention loans for small businesses
with loan forgiveness available for
businesses that continue paying work
I mean how about that 300 billion
dollars in direct cash payments are
being sent to every American citizen
earning less than 99 thousand dollars
per year $3,400 for the typical family
of four so they'll be getting a check
for three thousand four hundred dollars
for the typical family of four
approximately two hundred and fifty
billion dollars in expanded unemployment
benefits under this plan the average
worker who has lost his or her job will
receive 100% of their salary for up to
four full months the bill provides for
these unemployment checks to be
delivered through the existing state
unemployment systems not US State and I
was opposed to this method because many
of the states have very antiquated
computer systems that are forty-five
years old and they're not prepared to
handle this kind of distribution this
kind of money coming in so quickly
they're not set up for that and I didn't
want to do it but our opponents wanted
it so we did it and if they don't get
their money fast I'm going to ask that
we convene the federal government that
we come back to Congress and we'll do
something where we take care of it
because we can take care of it very
easily and quickly and I said that right
but a lot of these systems are so old
and so antiquated at the state level
that they're going to have the money
they're going to get the money very
quickly but they're not going to be able
to distribute it so remember what I said
and we will if we have to call Congress
back or find some other way of delivery
of the money throughout this great
national struggle the American people
have embodied the unrivaled patriotism
and willpower that has led America to
conquer every challenge every single one
in our nation's history more than 90
percent of Americans say they are
staying home as much as possible putting
their lives their careers their
education and their dreams on hold out
of devotion to their fellow citizens and
to their country social distancing
that's the way you win these shared
sacrifices are pulling our nation
together like never before family bonds
are strengthening neighbors are look
after neighbors it's incredible I'm
seeing you're seeing everybody's seeing
what's after I'm seeing that communities
are rallying for the cause and all the
visions are fading away the Americans of
every background are uniting to help our
nation in this hour of need
it's up to 151 countries so when we say
our nation our nation and the world
notice he never mentions case numbers
nor death numbers ever just doesn't
meant doesn't mention tragic death
doesn't it there's no empathy it's just
not it's not part of this you'd think he
is just a business situation we had that
many countries 151 countries at
something and some are struggling at a
level that nobody would have believed
possible if you look at Italy if you
look at France is having big problems
Spain is having incredible problems
something we did very well is when we
stop the inflow from China at a very
early level that was a good thing to do
a great thing to do we would have had
thousands and thousands a new we even
had a hundred and fifty one countries
did he just say that Europe at a very
early level but those things were very
important especially the initial one
because we had never done anything like
it where we closed our borders to a
country like that the modelling put
together by dr. Burks and dr. pouchy and
our other top healthcare acts I mean we
have and these people are amazing the
health care experts who in this country
are the best in the world they
demonstrate that the mitigation measures
we are putting in place may
significantly reduce the number of new
infections and ultimately the number of
fatalities I want the American people to
know that your selfless inspiring and
valiant efforts are saving countless
lives you are making the difference the
modeling estimates that the peak in
death rate is likely to hit in two weeks
so I'll say it again it's likely to be
the highest point of death rates you
remember this is likely to hit in two
weeks
that can last 10 days declaring victory
before the victory is won that would be
the greatest loss of all therefore the
next two weeks and during this period
it's very important that every one
strongly follow the guidelines have to
follow the guidelines that our great
vice president holds up a lot he's
holding that up a lot he believes in it
so strongly the better you do the faster
this whole nightmare will end therefore
we will be extending our guidelines Oh
to April 30th Wow to slow the spread no
II went Tuesday we'll be finalizing
these plans and providing a summary of
our findings supporting data and
strategy to the American people Easter's
done so we'll be having lots of meetings
in between but we'll be having a very
important statement made on Tuesday
probably Tuesday evening on all of the
findings all of the data and the reasons
we're doing things the way we're doing
them we can expect that by June 1st we
will be well on our way to recovery we
think by June 1st a lot of great things
will be happening I want every citizen
in our country to take heart and
confidence in the fact that we have the
best medical minds in the world tackling
this disease we have the best science
the best researches and the best talent
anywhere working night and day to
protect your family and loved ones and
to overcome this pandemic with the grace
of God we are rising to the occasion we
are proving that no darkness can
overshadow the eternal light of American
courage we will win and when we do we
will rebound with astonishing force and
speed we will be stronger than ever and
we will have learned so much where
something like this can never hurt us to
the extent it has and the world again
in our present crisis the strength of
our people is our single most important
asset and together we will defeat this
invisible curse this invisible enemy and
rise to incredible new heights so I just
want to thank you all for being here and
we'll take some questions if you'd like
yeah please Kelly in cases in the United
States and deaths could exceed 100,000
do you accept that assessment and has
that formed you were thinking about
extending these guidelines and you also
talked about New York were you
suggesting there has been inappropriate
use of masks or improper conduct with
supplies no I want the people in New
York to check Governor Cuomo mayor de
Blasio that when a hospital that's
getting 10,000 masks goes to 300,000
masks during the same period and that's
a rapid period I would like them to
check that because I hear stories like
that although they may be the really
we're delivering millions and millions
of different products and all we do is
hear that can you get some more but when
you hear that and I heard that from one
of the great companies of the world at
doing this it's a client and it goes
they go from you heard a 10,000 20,000
tops to 300,000 and that's a hospital
that's always full so I think people
should check that because there's
something going on whether it's not I
don't think it's hoarding I think it's
maybe worse than hoarding but check it
out check it out I don't know I think
other people to figure out totally based
but you don't go from numbers like that
man this guy's other equipment likewise
because we're delivering a lot of
ventilators we have those are we
building by the way we're building and
buying and we have a lot of ventilators
that where we're going to be sending out
very soon we also have right now in the
stockpile almost 10,000 ventilators that
we have to hold in case of emergency we
don't want them going out and then
Louisiana has a tremendous problem which
we now know they do yes a sudden it came
very
they came I mean Louisiana was doing so
fantastically well then all of a sudden
it was a big rash of cases called viral
growth so we have to be prepared to move
the ventilators are very important
pieces of equipment they're very
expensive and this guy with that you
know there weren't that many cases and
then there were it's so weird you know
these are expensive complicated very
complicated pieces of equipment so we
now have 10,000 and and we inherited a
system which was broken just like I'll
never forget the day when a general came
and said sir my first week in office we
have no ammunition oh here we was in the
military we've now this is literally
alive this is a known debunked story in
as you'd you wouldn't believe it how
much ammunition we have but the same
thing here we had we had a stockpile
that was deficient we had testing that
was no good we had a testing situation
that just wasn't right it was okay for
very small cases but it was obsolete and
it was broken and it was only good for a
very small situation but what I'd like
to do is I'd like to ask dr. Falchi to
come forward and discuss the number
because I think the number I think the
number is going to be a very different
number than the numbers that you talked
about please doctor you might talk about
that let's hope that mrs. president the
number I gave out is you know based on
modeling and I think it's entirely
conceivable that if we do not mitigate
to the extent that we're trying to do
that you could reach that number yeah
yeah yeah it's possible I mean you could
make a big sound byte about it but the
fact is it's possible what we're trying
to do is not let that happen
so instead of concentrating on the upper
and the lower who are saying that we're
trying to push it all the way down but
the second part of your question was yes
we feel that the mitigation that we're
doing right now is having an effect it's
very difficult to quantitate it because
you have to dynamic things going on at
the same time you have the virus going
up and you have the mitigation trying to
push it down but the decision to prolong
not prolong but to extend this
mitigation process until the end of
April I think was a wise
and prudent decision yes dr. Burks and I
spent a considerable amount of time
going over all the data why we felt this
was a best choice of us and the
president accepted it so in direct
answer to your question the idea that we
may have these many cases played a role
in our decision in trying to make sure
that we don't do something prematurely
and pull back when we should be pushing
yeah
they got through to essentially no
Easter parties no packed churches how
many lives did about you save with that
so thank you I mean you all know we've
all you've all seen the models you've
seen the models from Imperial you've
seen the models from Colombia we've
reviewed 12 different models and then we
went back to the drawing board over the
last week or two and worked from the
ground up utilizing actual reporting of
cases it's the way we built the HIV
model the TB model the malaria model and
when we finished on the other group that
was working in parallel which we didn't
know about h h IM e and chris Marie
ended up at the same numbers on so if
you go on his website you can see the
concern that we had with the great
growing number of potential fatalities
all of the flu models predicted of
anywhere between 1.6 and 2.2 million
fatalities if we didn't mitigate I think
you all knew those numbers
some of them predicted half of the
United States would get infected and
have that level of mortality so we've
worked very hard together to really look
at all of the impacts of the different
mitigations that have been utilized
around the world and use that evidence
base to really bring that data and
that evidence to the president to
consider for extending which is not a
simple situation when you ask people to
stay home for another 30 days come and
so they have to know that we've really
built this on scientific evidence and
the potential to save really hundreds of
thousands of American lives and we know
that's a huge sacrifice for everyone we
know is it's a sacrifice for every
mother and child and and father who's
also self isolating there are people
that have to go out to work and we know
the compromises that they're making but
it's all to protect not only Americans
but the health care providers the health
care providers that are on the front
lines and you've seen them and you've
seen how difficult this has been and so
we're really working there will be a
comprehensive piece presented on Tuesday
that really talks about not only
diagnosing individuals but also
increasing our surveillance now that we
have more test kits so that we can
really stop and contain new infections
at the same time we're really dedicating
test kits still to the critical
diagnosis so people can get the
treatment that they want and so that we
can ensure is when people come to the
hospital that they know that the nurses
and the doctors and the equipment that
they need will be there to serve them
because together as Americans we're
going to bring down the number of
infections so we don't have two point
two million deaths or 1.6 million deaths
but really work very hard to keep this
and at the lowest numbers we possibly
can
I just want to reiterate because a lot
of people have been asking well what
would have happened if we did nothing
did nothing we just wrote it out and
I've been asking that question to Tony
and Deborah and he said it would be mine
earlier talking to me about it for a
long time other people have been asking
that question and I think we got our
most accurate study today or certainly
most comprehensive I think of the number
two points you potentially 2.2 million
people if we did nothing if we didn't do
the distancing if we didn't do all of
the things that we're doing now when you
hear those numbers you start to realize
that with the kind of work we went
through last week with the 2.2 trillion
dollars it no longer sounds like a lot
right so you're talking about when I
heard the number today first time I've
heard that number cuz I've been asking
the same question that some people are
asking I felt even better about what we
did last week with the 2.2 trillion
dollars because you're talking about a
potential of up to 2.2 billion and some
people said it could even be higher than
that so you're talking about 2.2 million
deaths 2.2 million people from this we
know if we could hold that down as we're
saying to all that numbers been floating
around for a very long time he's
claiming he just heard that today but to
a hundred thousand so we have between a
hundred and two hundred thousand we all
together have done a very good job but
two points you up to 2.2 million deaths
and maybe even beyond that I'm feeling
very good about what we did last week
yes please go ahead please these
guidelines was floating Easter a mistake
do you think and know does this you can
tell us why it was just an aspiration we
actually will be hitting potentially and
this was with our meeting before on
Easter we probably they when that could
be a peak that could be a peak period
that could be the peak sadly to say that
could be the peak number of deaths
before it starts coming down
now that was aspirational we had a an
aspiration of Easter but when you hear
these kind of numbers and you hear the
potential travesty we don't want to do
anything we're you know we don't wanna
have a spike up we don't want to do it
soon and then all of a sudden you go
down you're coming down and then you
start going up again because we
discussed that could happen and we don't
want that to happen we've gone through
too much so that was an aspirational
number I didn't say Easter I said it
would be a great thing if we could do it
by Easter and we know much more now that
we knew two three weeks ago Easter
should be the peak number and it should
start coming down and hopefully very
substantially from that point okay thank
you please mr. president your approval
ratings have been the highest they've
ever been as well as the ratings on your
handling of the virus not anymore but
there are some networks that are saying
they're debating whether or not to carry
these briefings live do you think
there's a link between the two well I
don't know I know that my ratings well
that's a nice question thank you very
you tonight yeah I don't want high
approval ratings for this I wish we
could have our old life back we had the
greatest economy that we've ever had and
we didn't have death what I have this we
didn't have this horrible scourge
scourge this plague call it whatever you
want the virus but we're working very
hard that's all I know and you know I
see things I see numbers they don't
matter to me what matters to me is that
we have a victory over this thing as
soon as possible
that's Kor when you hear that 2.2
million people could have died if we
didn't go through all of this and and
now the number will be you know a much
lower number hopefully it's going to be
the numbers that we're talking about but
so I appreciate it very much but you
know what I want is I want our life back
again I want our country back I want the
world back I want the world to get rid
of this this again 151 countries and
we're gonna do we're gonna have a great
victory we're gonna have a great
go ahead please sorry but thanks you
mentioned it I just wanna make sure I
was right so Humana and Cigna are going
to waive for all costs for anybody
that's got the coronavirus they're gonna
take care of everything
well that's what they said I told you
what they're gonna take what the co-pays
in particular that's a big deal well
calling for insurance companies don't do
that and then come share this to you
mana and Cigna they should be getting a
lot of credit for that will there be
other companies or am there just those
two are getting a lot of credit right
now for it and they should because it
totally lied I mean it's a lot of money
they're waving and so we thank them will
there be other companies I wouldn't be
surprised are you Thomas doing spirit
I'll tell you what yeah I'd love to have
him do it let them wave those co-pays
there's a good true we don't know I mean
I know insurance companies better than
anybody they just don't do that but now
there's a spirit like I have not seen I
have never seen anything like it I mean
even the media is much more fair I
wouldn't say all of it but that's okay
they should be fair because they should
want to this to end this is just about
death so I want to thank Cigna and you
mana thank you well the federal
government be reimbursing those
insurance companies or is this something
they really are just doing out of their
pocket boys do they have an ask for
reimbursement so I assume the nurse
isn't gonna wait on write a bathing it
doesn't mean we're gonna waive them and
get reimbursed don't okay and second
question for you sir I first of the
month is three days away
I know these cash payment treasury
secretary my douching said today about
three weeks they should get there for
people that are worried about paying
rent
I know mortgages through the HUD is
taken care of but I'm just curious about
rent what should people be doing for the
first not to be getting the money I will
tell you these landlords are gonna take
it easy we may put out a statement on
that not a lot of people that are owed
money you're gonna take it easy
landlords are gonna take it easy at
kushner is enforcing pay rent on April 1
no questions asked insurance companies a
lot of concessions are being made that
wouldn't have even been thought of three
weeks ago not even thought of so a lot
of really positive things are happening
please behind you Thank You mr.
president yesterday why did you publicly
threatened
or insane on New York New Jersey part I
didn't read the statement read the
statement read what I said I said we're
gonna look into possibly quarantine I
didn't say we're going to quarantine I
looked at it as a possibility because a
lot of our professionals suggested
quarantine nasty I said whether to look
at it we then looked at it you see who
you with Bloomberg right I can't imagine
that let me just say I didn't threaten
edit go around threatening what happened
is people professionals but a family
good professionals love the idea of
doing that because that sort of the
ultimate in distancing you can't do they
didn't want New Yorkers were there
having a problem necessarily going down
to Florida where they have less of a
problem so the concept of quarantine was
thrown out to me really would love to do
what they would love to do it and I
thought it was too much to do because
the people are doing a great job with it
also it's very hard to enforce but by
speaking about it publicly I mean by
speaking about it publicly and letting
you know be known that it's a
consideration do you think that you may
be frightened somehow I think a people
aware to stay in your houses and do good
now we did an advisory it's a strong
advisory the governor's are running the
advisory the three governor's New York
New Jersey Connecticut and I think we
did a great thing but all I did
yesterday as you know you can see it you
can read it you can read and you can see
very simply that I said that we are
looking into it and then before the end
of the evening substantially we decided
to go with the advisory which frankly I
liked better from the beginning going
right I have two questions the first is
you've said repeatedly that you think
that some of the equipment that
governors are requesting they don't
actually need you said New York might
need that may not need 30,000 you said
it on Sean Hannity's Fox News he said
you know you said what act why don't you
act in a little more positive it's
always trying to my question to you head
you get you and you know what that's why
nobody trusts the media anymore that's
why he how's that gonna come yeah isn't
here me that's why you used to work for
The Times and now you work for somebody
else look let me tell you something be
nice don't it surprise the right
question don't be threatening
be nice my question is how is that gonna
impact how you fill these orders for
ventilators or for mass your views that
we're producing tremendous numbers of
ventilators we're doing a great job Mike
Pence our Vice President is headed up
the task force which has been incredible
the job they've done we have everybody
and the White House working on it we
have everybody in the country is working
on this in one way or the other the fact
is we've done a great job of delivering
you've seen the biggest people in the
business I mean there's nobody even
close to this group of people we had a
meeting at 3 o'clock it lasted for a
long time it was a great meeting with
the generals and with everybody else and
they have done a fantastic job I'm just
saying this if they're holding let me
give you one example we sent thousands
of generators to New York they were put
into a warehouse a New York warehouse
that happened to be located interesting
ly in Edison New Jersey they were given
to New York and we then went to other
places also giving thousands of
ventilators the people in New York never
distributed the generators we said why
does yes rip it up now you have to
understand they have New York people
working in those warehouses they knew
they Adam so we said why didn't you
distributor I'm just I hope they've
distributed them now right but maybe
they didn't need them so badly but just
so you know we're all you me everybody
we're all on the same team you know when
when journalists get up and you're a
journalist to find journalists when
journalists get on hannity and ask
questions that are so threatening i was
quoting from your interviews on hannity
quoting it was the break a look at my
interview what i want to do is if there
is something wrong we have to get to the
bottom of it when I hear facemasks go
from 10,000 to 300,000 and they
constantly need more and the biggest man
and the business is like shocked he
knows all about the virus by the way
he's not surprised by that he knows all
about it
he shouldn't be surprised he should say
what a standard because this is really a
very tough disease this is really a very
tough virus to handle okay my second
question is president my figure that's
enough thank you very much
one question please please see question
that's enough
that's enough that's not fair to your
other reporters it's not fair you had a
long time a long question it sure if we
have time I'll get back to you for your
second question is that okay all right
thank you I appreciate it
just to follow up on previous questions
you said that the ping will hit in two
weeks well we don't know that but we
think the peak will hit you think it
will hit is doctors here can you just
share with us your understanding of how
bad it will be so the American people
will be prepared for it well I can I
think I'll ask doctor and doctor maybe
you could both come up and give your
opinion in that because that's really
and I have another question
ladies thank you I mean we have great
concerns when you look at the model as I
told you look at the Chris Murray model
chuckle shows a rapid escalation and you
can see it happening but the people
we're losing every day throughout them
throughout America and you can see it
going up just like cases and we're
starting to lose people at the same rate
and we have deep concerns about that and
I think we're meeting and we've had
calls with the clinicians and that has
been extraordinarily helpful I think
you're watching the alerts I mean we
have a different population than Italy
or Spain and so because of that our
doctors and our nurses are getting
information back really quickly so that
they can talk to each other about how to
really combat this we're seeing things
here that weren't reported in other
countries and so I really want to
appreciate it I know doctors and nurses
are going full out but they're also
taking the time and there are two hours
of sleep to write us about what could be
happening when you see the
cardiovascular disease and others so in
the model and there's a there's a large
confidence interval and so it's anywhere
in the model between 80,000 and 160,000
maybe even potentially 200,000 people
succumbing to this that's with
mitigation in that model they make full
assumption that we continue doing
exactly what we're doing but even better
in every metro area with a level of
intensity
because we're hoping that the models are
not completely right that we can do
better than what the predictions are but
we're tracking it very closely and I
think there's people around the United
States really helping us scientists
across the country have really given
freely of their time to really help us
not only model this but really assure
that the American public knows how
important it is that they stay doing
this you know you could see from the
recent data and I have dr. Falchi talk
about young people that are being
impacted here we didn't see that that
the same way in Europe but our
population is about 8 or 9 years younger
and so we have to be attentive to all
aspects of this to children to young
people to adults we know still the
people with pre-existing conditions and
the elderly are at particularly high
risk but we don't want to lose any
American and so that's why I think the
president came to the conclusion that at
a minimum we have to continue what we've
been doing but even better to every
metro area out there we have to do
better we have to ensure that we're
protecting each other
Tony you are so at the risk of offending
my modelling colleagues models are good
but models often generate the kind of
anxious question that you asked is how
bad could this possibly get and as I've
said many many times a model is as good
as the assumptions that you put into the
model and very often many of these
sumption --zz are based on a complexity
of issues that aren't necessarily the
same as dr. Berg said from one country
to the other so when you give a model
you have the worst extreme you have the
best extreme often the worst extreme
means that you don't do anything you
just as we say let it rip and let it go
let it rip if you go to the lower end
that means you've actually mitigated
really to the utmost so what I like to
do as a scientist a physician a public
health official is to not ignore models
but say look at the data as its evolving
and do everything you possibly
can to mitigate that instead of getting
overly anxious about the extremes of the
model again not to push them aside
completely but the reason the president
made the announcement today about going
to the end of April is because we want
to make sure that we don't prematurely
think we're doing so great we may be but
we want to push it to the extreme so
take that with you and maybe you'll be
less anxious okay
therefore in Poole sir
you mentioned Italy just just to finish
with so so what both were saying and
what dr. pouchy just brought up we don't
want to do well and then end a little
bit early and have it start going up we
correctly responsible thing to say a
disaster go ahead right you mentioned
Italy Italy is a close ally of the
United States the effacing catastrophic
time yes they have been receiving help
from countries like Russia China even
Cuba human doctors have been sent to
Italy is the United States stepping in -
yes last night with our people we're
sending them a lot of different things
that we're not needing because we're
obviously in need of a lot also and
we're also helping them monetarily we
are helping Italy a lot we're working
very closely with Italy we're working
closely with Spain - which is really hit
hard and we're working with everybody I
spoke with uncle Merkel the other day
Germany's hit hard their mortality rate
is different I think because they do
more testing but their mortality rate is
much different Italy's mortality rate is
very high he's been talking about how we
do the most testing now he says well
Germany does more testing so they've got
a lower rate I thought we were testing
more than anyone else come up and just
talk a little bit about the tremendous
success that's been made on testing from
where we started thank you
Thank You mr. president so as of close
of business yesterday we have been able
to perform in the United States over 894
thousand tests so highly significantly
increased every single day those tests
are performed at a number of places in
hospitals in your neighborhood in the
public health laboratories the state
public health laboratories and in our
territories as well as the large
reference laboratories that are members
of the American Clinical Laboratory
Association they have done over 650
thousand tests including over eight
hundred and forty thousand just
yesterday I met with all their CEOs
yesterday they're fully committed to
increasing testing to meet the requests
and the demands or the president and
vice president a couple words on the
point-of-care test point of care means
you stop you get the result right there
that the president the vice president
have talked about by abbot approved in
record time by dr. Steve Hahn and the
FDA this is a point-of-care test meaning
that from the time to swab to the time
you get a positive result five minutes
like the president said and at at most
15 minutes for a negative result so just
think of it as a 15 minute test this is
not an esoteric test there are 18,000 of
these Little Toaster size machines all
over the country in doctors offices and
hospitals right now an abbot will be
providing 50,000 or more tests per day
starting on April 2nd with the first
shipments out already this complements
other point-of-care testing like the
Cepheid tests that we announced about a
week ago we also have moderate platforms
so it's not just about the number it's
the type we have point of care we have
moderate platforms that are in hospitals
in in larger clinics and academic
medical centers and then we have the
very large tests you've heard ambassador
birx talk about the Roche tests and the
ROS platforms that are in some of these
big reference laboratories so it's not
just about the number but it's about
painting this very complex ecosystem so
that everybody who needs a test can get
a test
on priorities remember we are still
prioritizing those in most need those
who are in hospitals or in icy use
because that test makes a difference to
how they're being treated symptomatic
first responders health care workers and
as administrator Verma will always say
those in long-term care facilities who
are at high risk too one last point I've
learned more about nasal swabs than I
ever thought I would want to learn in my
entire life but it was a very big thing
that the FDA approved last week and it
will now be implemented this week
instead of having a provider stick this
all the way in the back of your nose
that's uncomfortable but it also
requires PPE changes every time it's
done the FDA approved with lots of data
supporting it self swab of your nose so
literally put a swab certain kind of
swab foam swabbing your nose put it in a
plastic bag give it in and drop it this
not only increases the speed but it
eliminates all those changes of PPE so
we will be implementing that this week
which will increase speed but also save
our precious resources as we build them
up in the stockpile and out to hospitals
thank you sorry
Thank You Adam oh very much yeah please
go
mr. president you mentioned that the
peak could come in two weeks can you
ensure that everyone that needs a
ventilator every single patient that
needs one will get get one will it get
there in time and my second question is
after invoking the defense production
act yesterday with GM you said that
there were a couple of problem children
that may require using your authority
again
what are those companies and what aren't
they meeting well I don't have to tell
you because those companies have come
into line they're doing a great job
they're working very hard 24 hours
around the clock so I don't want to give
their names now because they are they've
been great they've come into line and by
the way General Motors is doing a
fantastic job I don't think we have to
worry about General Motors now they've
really been relator quite a job and what
the Admiral said also I think we can add
this Admiral the reason we show more
cases than anybody else in the world is
we're doing more testing than anybody
else it just said Germany's death
testing more and thus has a lower death
rate testing than anybody in the world
and remember we started with a system
that was broken for many years it was
broken and I'm not blaming the last
administration I'm saying other
administration's and our pipeline had
very little in it just like we had no
ammunition we had very little medical we
had very little in our pipeline now we
have ammunition more than hopefully
we'll ever need and we also have a
pipeline that's packed and now we have
those 10,000 ventilators that we can use
because you need some quickly I mean
these this this goes quickly from place
to place I'd love to give them all out
right now but we need them quickly I
don't want to give them out and then we
have to take them back and move them
someplace else so we're very much
prepared please
mr. president states like Florida have
reportedly had 100% of their requests
for supplies from the National strategic
stockpile filled but other states like
Massachusetts have not so how was that
assessment being made and why has
Florida gotten its requests well I think
you're gonna find that most almost all
states look I was on the call yesterday
with the governors and they were happy
with the job we're doing and I'll tell
you what if you had a different
administration they would not have been
happy these are people that speak their
mind they were happy
it was falsely reported by a couple of
people that whoa gee they weren't they
were happy they were thrilled taken care
of and Michigan has been taken care very
yes what you say to me it's very
important because I'm so proud of what
we've done
bringing car companies back into
Michigan and we're now dealing with the
governor and I think Mike I can say that
a lot of good things are happening in
Michigan westenra's Matthew
Massachusetts we're dealing with the
governor very strongly and we're trying
to get things to Massachusetts as
rapidly as possible we're dealing I
received 100% of its requests compared
to some other states Florida look
they're very aggressive in trying to get
things and they're doing a very good job
but I think I think I can say all of the
governors are very committed we're very
Kepler 'added asking better and we're
getting things out at a level that
nobody's ever seen before we can you can
speak to FedEx you can speak to ups you
can speak they've never done anything
like this that what they're doing right
now and nobody in the world has been
able to match what these great companies
have been able to do if we left that to
government it would have been a tough
thing we have mobilized private
enterprise we have mobilized the
greatest companies in the world and
what's happening is incredible and that
includes Abbott where Abbott comes out
and all of a sudden out of nowhere comes
up with this incredible test that
simplifies everything it makes it so
easy so I think you're gonna find most
states are very happy I'm dealing with
the governor of Louisiana John bel
Edwards he's a Democrat if that's what
you're getting at but I'm dealing with
him very successfully I think he's very
happy I think he's actually amazed at
what he's been able to get in fact we
were even forward thinking I suggested
we said additional ventilators
other things we're building a hospital
in Louisiana very importantly we're
building hospitals in New Jersey
governor Murray Murphy of New Jersey is
a terrific guy and frankly he's he wants
you know he's got a pretty hot spot
right there right next to New York and
we're doing hospitals we're doing
ventilators we're getting a lot -
governor Murphy that's New Jersey yeah
last night I spoke to the governor of
Blessed I spoke to the governor of
Connecticut we know and talked with him
we are really doing a job look gavin
newsom the governor of california he's
been he's been terrific we sent him a
boat way ahead of schedule the ship way
ahead of schedule hospital ship the
mercy with a thousand beds operating
rooms and it's it's been la for three
days already so I think they're really
happy and when you think about it in New
York we build 2900 hospital rooms beds
nobody's ever seen it before
the governor's never seen anything like
that before this was done by federal
government not by state government this
was done by the federal government
they're opening it tomorrow I wanted to
be there so badly but Secret Service and
all of the people involved won't let me
they won't let me I would love to be
there but they won't let me for obvious
reasons but I would have loved to have
been at the opening tomorrow of the
hospital in New York Javits Center at
you have it Center but we're very proud
of the job we've done we've mobilized
and getting better and better every day
and the task force headed by your vice
president the job they've done and they
don't even sleep okay any other
questions may I just follow up on your
letter to the governor's that you say
since we were on the topic of governor's
he sent a letter to governor's at the
end of the week saying that you guys are
going to be developing criteria to being
able to classify counties based on where
they were hotspots or whatnot and I
wanted to know if you have enough tests
currently to be able to accurately rank
those counties
yeah we're ranking counties that were
ranking States and a lot of people put
out false information as a whole they
don't know what they're telling
everybody and we took over a dead barren
system we took over a system that was
obsolete it was it was good for a tiny
little sample of people it was and even
that didn't work because when CDC first
look at their tests the biggest problem
they had is the test didn't work that
wasn't from us that's been there a long
time now we have the best tests in the
world and nobody has nether roll-call
and can we get the quick tests we call
it the quick test where by the way
probably more accurate and it takes a
few minutes I mean it's pretty amazing
what we've done incredibly now we're
getting good we're getting along great
with the governor's yeah go ahead please
it was about counties no go ahead please
thank you so much mr. president I wanted
to ask you more specifically about this
strategy that you plan to unveil on
Tuesday what factors are you taking into
consideration what can the American
people expect fall and is it possible
that these April 30th guidelines could
be extended well we hope not
but we think it's going to you know we
have aspirational thoughts we would have
loved to have been a little bit sooner
but we have to do it right we could have
done it we could have done it on Easter
but there was a good chance that if it's
coming down or if it's still going up
maybe it's going to be coming down by
that but we just felt it was too soon we
can't take a chance you know the right
that's it again because of what we've
done and because of with the fact that
we've stopped the flow from China so
early because the question is from a lot
of my friends why don't we just wing it
why didn't we just wing it and I kept
asking and we did models now finally we
got these models in and you hear about
the 2.2 million people would have died I
don't mean we would have had two point
two million cases these are 2.2 million
people would have died 2.2 million
people look we're going to have a
meeting or speech or press conference or
something on Tuesday I thought what I do
I was going to announce the end of April
on Tuesday but I said let's do it now
because somewhere along the line it's
gonna leak we might as well just do it
now and get there with all the leaks
this way it didn't nice and
clean but we have to really do a great
job for another couple of weeks and I
think we're gonna be in great shape and
we're going to be in a position even
with what we're trying to do with
restaurants with deductibility we have
to get these restaurants back in we have
to get our businesses open we have to
get the planes flying we have to get
everything going we have to get even the
cruise ships I mean we have to get those
cruise ships moving along we had the
greatest economy in the history of the
world three weeks ago and now we've said
please don't work anymore we're actually
paying people not to work nobody's that
we really learned about three weeks ago
the economy is that even an economy that
has a bunch of stickers on it that
looked pretty good there's an underlying
fragility in other words it's held
together with tape is what we learned on
the outside and maybe it's not even on
that side we don't know is 2.2 million
people would have died if we didn't do
what we're doing and now we're looking
at numbers that are going to be much
much much lower than that and it makes
everything we're doing feel much better
to me please go ahead thanks sir I do
have a question for you but I'd like to
let my colleague give me you know Thank
You mr. president
you've also said that at one point that
you thought more people might die from
the economic tragedies and the economic
problems in America due to the corona
virus outbreak what health officials are
telling you that and dr. Fauci could you
speak to that the idea that there might
be mental health and suicide related to
this with that outpace at some point the
viruses impact on this uniting question
well thank you dr. fout you to come up
but it's common sense you're gonna have
massive depression meaning mental
depression you can have depression and
the economy also but you're gonna have
mental depression not a fear about those
numbers you're gonna have large numbers
of suicides take a look what happens in
a really horrible recession or worse so
you're going to have tremendous suicides
but you know what you're gonna have more
than anything else
drug addiction but you'll see drugs
being used like nobody's ever used them
before and people are going to be dying
all over the place for from drug
addiction from quitting you would have
rugged
one little job at a restaurant or even
owned a restaurant I spoke to great
people today that have done a great job
and one day they're at the top of their
business their celebrity chefs they've
got the most successful restaurants and
in one day they have nothing they've
gotten wiped out one day from our enemy
this invisible horrible scourge so when
you ask me that it's it's so easy to
figure that I mean massive drug use
massive depression mental depression
massive numbers of suicide anxiety
causes you know disease they say a lot
of people you're gonna have tremendous
and hopefully we're not gonna have that
because hopefully by what we're doing we
get the best of both worlds I don't have
2.2 million deaths we have a number
that's much less much much less and at
the same time we get our country running
again please thank you thank you mr.
president
you were next he was very nice in doing
it though nevertheless go ahead thank
you this is unusual for CNN to two quick
questions
first of all during this 30-day
additional period do you anticipate at
all relaxing those restrictions by
region during these additional every day
think so I think it's a great question
actually I don't think so when I asked
that the same as that's the right answer
Nebraska how about Idaho how about Iowa
and you know what those people is so
great the whole Midwest they want to I
don't think they want to be in that
position actually remember they're not
even doing anything yet I was getting
pretty strong look by these two people
they said we don't like that idea so you
know we're relying on them they're the
best in their profession and they didn't
like the idea and secondly sir I want to
ask you better we could do it but I
don't think it would be good thank you
sir
I'll also like to ask you about some
comments you made on Friday you were
talking about governors of different
states and you said I want them to be
appreciative you also said if they don't
treat you right I didn't I don't call
these are direct direct quotes sir
excuse me
ready ready take a look at what said I
want them to be appreciative of me okay
and then you cut it off because it's
fake those UN of your administration
please let me
just finished the quote the quote said
it again and you know the answers a lie
you know I could read your soul comments
let me say your statement and your
response and your answer is a lie how to
use the story you ready
I said I want you to be appreciative of
me and then you go on and then I go on
and you cut it off but it says when
you're not appreciative I don't want
them to say things that aren't true I
want them to be appreciative we've done
a great job and I'm not talking about me
I'm talking about Mike Pence the task
force I'm talking about that yeah the
Army Corps of Engineers thank you but
they went on to say if they don't treat
you right
I don't call he's a different type of I
don't call referring so I don't know no
I don't call the governor of wash this
time but Mike Pence calls and the head
of FEMA calls I don't stop then did I
ever ask you to do anything negative
Mike to Washington to the state of
Washington Michigan I love that stuff
that's one of my favorite places in the
whole world Michigan and I'm so proud of
what's happened with the auto industry
it's coming back to Michigan no I don't
have to call us what I'm probably better
off not because we don't get he's a
failed presidential candidate he's a
nasty person I don't like the governor
of Washington so you know who calls I
get Mike Pence to call I get the head of
FEMA took call I get the Admiral to plan
but what you didn't say so you started
it off everything you talked about I
have to be appreciative but then when
you read the rest said because if you
don't appreciate you're not respecting
these incredible people the two Admirals
you're not appreciating FEMA advert and
the Army Corps of Engineers who built
2,900 beds in three and a half days and
you're not appreciating all of the work
that's been done and you're not
appreciating these incredible medals
from private enterprise that are
delivering things in numbers that nobody
has ever seen
see and that's why people aren't
watching CNN very much anymore that's
why they don't like it that's why your
ratings are no good because you even
after knowing the truth for days now you
bring up the old lie oh my god read the
read the rest of your thing is his
followers believe this they'll never
realize that the guys reading a quote
verbatim and it said in their FEMA and
it said in their Army Corps of Engineers
because when they disrespect me they're
disrespecting our government and you
know what triggered I don't
if I'm disrespected but they can't
disrespect the Army Corps of Engineers
and FEMA why is the lack of a place go
ahead I want them to appreciate the
incredible job we're doing we are doing
a job the likes of which has never been
done before and there are a couple of
people that know that but for political
reasons let's say they're Democrats they
don't want to give this administration
credit and that's okay but I don't have
to deal with them but our Vice President
does deal with them please go ahead
thank you Miss that's why CNN is not
trusted anymore they are not trusted
they are fake news remember that go
ahead yes you are
go ahead Thank You mr. president I
wanted to ask you about the extension of
the CDC guidelines you've announced yay
through the end of next month and of
course you know that there have been a
shelter-in-place orders they've been
have been imposed by governors and
mayor's all throughout the country and
when you take that all into account it
sounds like and it seems like you've
acknowledged that America essentially
will be shut down for the next few weeks
maybe even the next two months you
mentioned June 1st as a date in which
you like no we think it's going to
really start to open up we think that
that's going to be the bottom of the
hill that's where we're looking at June
1st maybe even a little bit sooner than
that so we have this hill if we did
nothing the hill would have been up here
we did a lot we did just about maxis
some stay we'd get because we stopped
China from coming in and then later on
we stopped Europe from we got lucky we
got very lucky the people that were
coming in here they went to Italy they
went to Spain they went to other
countries we got lucky and they got
unlucky to be honest with you you look
at what's going on in Italy in Spain in
particular so no I don't want that June
1st we think we can reach the bottom of
that hill on June 1st and that would be
a great thing and and I have confidence
in the two of the two doctors I think
that that could be a data could even be
sooner could be a little bit later it
could be sooner but I think people would
be very happy if we did a job and saved
potentially millions of lives I think
people would be very happy with that
date questions sir actually yes please
mr. president my question actually has
to do with the 2.2 trillion dollar
relief bill yeah that you signed in
in your in your view do you think that
another relief bill another phase bill
may be necessary and are you prepared to
support that mr. president well I'm
prepared to do whatever is necessary to
number one save lives and number two
bring our economy back strong just like
it was before
I think our economy has a chance to be
just as good and even better than it was
before and remember a lot of the money
that you read about that's all coming
back these are loans to great companies
that got stopped from doing business
they'll be back very soon so much of the
money that we're talking about that
money's coming back and we'll take
warrants meaning we'll take pieces of
the company for the taxpayers of their
organization says I expect it will make
a lot of money with that money we're
gonna make a lot of money and it's Tokyo
do you want to talk about making money
they're gonna take pieces of companies
now things number one is saving lives
and number two is bringing our economy
back okay but I think we're gonna do
very well that hold money I hope it's
coming back please mr. president thank
you this afternoon you had tweeted that
there are on average eight point five
million Americans tune into these daily
press briefings that are you know
concerned about taking these briefing
says no I know exactly what you saying
no I've read that what do you think well
I've read that CNN doesn't want to cover
them I've read that except they can't
help them because the ratings are so
high the rain you know if the ratings
were low they wouldn't be here this man
wouldn't be here in a hundred years you
could be people are watching because
they're scared and people they're dying
not because this is like The Bachelor or
the Super Bowl we help their ratings we
help we lift up they're ready because
their ratings are very low but for the
most part I haven't heard that I will
say the Washington Post has a drive-on
not to go to the President of the United
States news conference because frankly
so many people are watching we're
getting the word out we're getting the
accurate word out and a lot of people
are happy about it
and a lot of people aren't but they
should be happy when I have the general
when I have Seema and when I have Tony
and what I have are incredibly czar all
like people that have become big stars
okay but they've done a great job but
Debra has done a fantastic on a virus
they don't want to be still
you know what they want they want to win
they want to win the battle against
server they've been fighting this stuff
their whole life between Ebola and swine
flu and I don't know I'm not sure I'd
love your life but that's what you like
right that's what they do they fight
disease and you know what there's nobody
that does it better but I think the
American public ultimately they should
be the decider it's like if they don't
want to watch they shouldn't watch and
we shouldn't have bigger ratings than
the bachelor or weaponised as the New
York Times said we have Monday Night
Football type ratings now I didn't say
that I have no idea what they are in a
sense but I know that the times they say
it's all the news that's fit to print I
say it's all the news it's not fit to
print because I think they are not
honest people but that's okay but they
can't help it but even they said that
the ratings are like Monday Night
Football ratings and that these are like
bachelor finale that's their end when
the big deal happened I have no idea
what happened because I'm too busy
working on this someday you will tell me
what happened so no I think it's
terrible when they don't want the
President of the United States to have a
voice wow you're not talking about
democracy any longer please thank you
very much beautiful question
I thinks mr. president you've talked a
lot about concerns about leaving for so
long
was there any dissent from your top
economic advisors and your decision to
leave the guidelines in place at the end
of April no and this is before we heard
the 2.2 million people I mean we had a
lot of people were saying maybe we
shouldn't do anything just write it they
say write it like a cowboy just write it
ride that sucker right through that's
where the 2.2 million people come in
would have died maybe but it would have
been 1.6 to 2.2 and that's not
acceptable
but there were a lot of people that said
I thought about it I said maybe we
should write it through you know you
always hear about the flu I talk about
it all the time we had a bad flu season
we're in the midst of a bad flu system
you know we had a bad season last year
as an example a bad flu season and
you'll have 35 36 37 thousand people die
sometimes more sometimes less but this
is different and part of this is the
unknown and part of it also is the
viciousness of it I had a friend who
went to a hospital the other day he's a
little older and he's heavy anybody's a
tough person
okay went to the hospital in a day later
he's in a coma I call how's he doing sir
he's in a coma he's unconscious he's not
doing well that the speed and the
viciousness especially if it gets the
right person it's horrible it's really
horrible please God through
mr. president I may be good for some of
the advisors as well we've heard some
rumors that Louisiana is really gonna
get hit hard next because it's
possibility that Mardi Gras have you
guys seen any data to back that up of
what happened a few weeks ago whether or
not that's contributing to the spike in
Louisiana I don't think it's a rumor I
think it's a fact
Louisiana's been hit hard and Louisiana
is an example it started off with like
nobody for so long I spoke when I spoke
tonight with Brad yeah but Debra or Tony
any yes the virus spreads virally yep
that's true you know I think you've
heard us talk about a week ago that we
were very worried about the numbers and
how they were increasing in Louisiana
how they were increasing in Cook County
how they were increasing in Dearborn and
Detroit and I think those are areas that
we're still watching very carefully and
like the president said when people get
this virus some people do very poorly
and when certain metro areas get exposed
to the virus we see this really very
rapid expansion of the virus we think it
may been circulating there for you know
a couple of weeks we don't like to I
don't like to look backwards I only like
to look forwards and really we are
putting all of our effort into ensuring
that the people of New Orleans the
people of the Detroit region sort
frankly the people of New York I mean
that some of the fastest growing
counties are not New York itself in New
York City when you look o at at per
hundred thousand its Rockland its Bergen
so I mean these are all of these places
are people that have transited through
cities and that's why we really did want
the travel advisory just to really warn
people to watch out for their own health
to really take their temperatures and so
it can go from 50 hundred five hundred
cases and the next thing you know it's
2,000 it's 4,000 it's 10,000
because it then gets across all
communities people get very sick you
know you made the comment about New
Orleans this can happen anywhere and
that's really one of the issues that
we're concerned about and why we were so
reluctant to pull back at a time when we
need to put a foot on the gas as opposed
to on the brake and as with dr. Berg
said this is exactly what you see there
are a number of communities cities or
states what-have-you out there in which
they're trickling along like that don't
get complacent about that because that's
exactly the way the virus works it goes
like this and like this and then it goes
up like that that's exactly what
happened in New Orleans that's what
happened in a terrible way with New York
that's what we're trying to avoid in
multiple locations throughout the
country so we shouldn't take any solace
when we see low levels in different
states different cities different areas
of course they're very vulnerable to an
explosion right mr. president last
question for me sir just real quick I
asked the vice president a week ago and
I think we talked about it last week as
well you took the test that first time I
remember that and I think you took it
last week mr. vice president
yeah a chance to take it again does it
get easier the second time around is
that house I think I'm waiting for that
little 45 minute test I sort of like
that or now it's down to five minutes I
understand but no I haven't but I think
I'll I think I will take it again if
it's appropriate I don't feel there's
any symptoms I don't notice have you
noticed any sniffles nothing right yes
well he's so far I haven't felt that way
but you know there was a big strong
point made originally I think it still
holds take the test if you need it if
you have the symptoms if you don't don't
take it that's put out by the
professionals so you know I don't have
it but I would I would take it I just
wanted to say one thing also about what
Tony had mentioned so I grew up in
Queens New York and right next to a
place called
Elmhurst Queens beautiful and have a
hospital that's a very good Hospital
Elmhurst Hospital right I've done it
I've known where it is I can tell you
the color on the outside the size of the
windows I mean I know it very well right
that was
near my community where I lived and I've
been watching that for the last week on
television
body bags all over in hallways I've been
watching them bring in trailer trucks
freezer trucks their freezer trucks
because they can't handle the bodies
there's so many of them this is in my
essentially in my community in Queens
Queens New York I've seen things that
I've never seen before I mean I've seen
them but I've seen them on television in
faraway lands I've never seen them in
our country Elmer's Hospital
unbelievable people I mean I when I see
the trucks pull up to take out bodies
and he's a truck setter as long as the
Rose Garden and they're pulling up to
take out bodies and you look inside and
you see the black body bags you say
what's in there it's Elmer's hospital
must be supplies it's not supplies it's
people I've never seen anything like it
so we're doing these people are doing a
fantastic job and somebody else who's
doing a fantastic job is sitting here
who is the head of the task force and I
just maybe want to finish up because I'd
like to ask Mike what do you think about
what we've done and where do you think
we're going and how do you feel also and
you studied this so closely how do you
feel like they're real sticklers and the
June first date and that's a very that's
aspirational but I think that's really
modified aspirational because I think
we're gonna hit it and maybe we'll even
beat it okay Mike Plews Thank You mr.
president and let me just join you in
thanking the American people yes for the
efforts of people this nation have made
over the past 15 days and that we know
they will continue to make over the next
30 you heard the president speak today
about the modeling and on Tuesday he
will share with the nation the full
range of counsel of the team that he
assembled now months ago at the White
House coronavirus task force will lay
out to the country what could
Ben but what we're continuing to work to
make a reality but in the meantime every
American I think every American should
have a a grateful heart first and
foremost all the incredible health care
workers that are on the front lines at
places like Elmhurst and elsewhere every
single day as dr. Burke said getting
just a few hours of sleep and going
right back into work I mean they are the
hands and feet of American compassion
and I want to say on behalf of your
president on behalf of a grateful nation
that were with you we're going to
continue to work tirelessly with these
outstanding leaders at FEMA to make sure
that you have the protective equipment
to be able to do your job safely and and
go home to your family we're going to
continue to work with these incredible
distributors literally the aircraft that
landed at JFK this morning is the first
of 51 aircraft that are going to be
coming in from around the world and it's
all headed to support our health care
workers and people that are on the front
lines but also mr. president I want to
say thank you to American businesses
whose generosity is shining forth every
day the two insurance companies that you
mentioned have waived co-pays and are
providing full coronavirus coverage to
Americans for the full treatment that
people that are enduring this virus are
experiencing but American businesses
like those so well represented here are
stepping up every day with what the
president likes to call a spirit the
likes of which we haven't seen for quite
a while in this country and it's truly
inspiring I also want to join your words
about this team that you've assembled
not only the healthcare team the
extraordinary team at FEMA and HHS but
all of our partners at the state and
local level the work that they're doing
mr. president when you tapped me to do
this five weeks ago you said I want a
full partnership with our states I want
to want to make sure the federal
government is there working working with
our governors and all the local health
officials
and to all of you who are managing your
states to all of you that are
implementing those healthcare policies
on the local level you have our
admiration and our commitment to
continue to be with you I think what the
president laid out today while it is I'm
sure for many Americans that were hoping
we would be with this sooner there may
be a modest sense of frustration and
disappointment but what I hear speaking
to these health care experts is that
there is light at the end of the tunnel
and that if as the American people
continue to put into practice the
president's coronavirus guidelines for
America's each one of us continues to do
our part social distancing avoiding
groups of more than 10 using a
drive-thru at local restaurants avoiding
unnecessary travel as every American
continues to listen to your state and
local leaders to heat that domestic
travel advisory that the CDC issued on
Saturday night we're gonna hasten the
day that that we get to the other side
of this as the president said and that
what we truly do believe that while
there are challenges in the weeks ahead
there is hope that as every American
continues to put these guidelines into
practice as every single one of us
continues to do our part that we'll get
through this I mean when the American
people know the how tall the hill is mr.
president we've never failed to get over
it and then some and I think with your
leadership with this extraordinary team
that you've assembled with the great
leadership that we have at state and
local levels the partnership with
American businesses and the can-do
spirit of the American people will get
through this and we'll get through this
together thank you I thank you
so I just want to end by saying that
we're all in this together
all of us I have never seen anything
like it spirit the unity the esprit de
corps the spirit I've never seen
anything like it it's a beautiful thing
to watch
unfortunately the enemy is death its
death a lot of people are dying so it's
very unpleasant it's a very unpleasant
thing to go through but the level of
competence the level of caring the level
of love I just think it's it's brilliant
and it's possibly happening happening in
other countries possibly I don't know I
can't speak to other countries but I can
speak to the United States of America
and I've said it before and I'll say it
again I am very proud to be your
president thank you very much thank you
everybody
thank you wow what a day what a day what
a day what can we really say the big
news of course that we are indeed going
to have an additional 32 days from today
of the guidelines domestic travel
warning remember some states haven't
started so we are still operating in
this delusional place where places like
Massachusetts where I am have been doing
this for weeks already and Donald Trump
is talking about extending it and of
course many places have not yet started
so it is going to be it's gonna be it's
gonna be a month it's gonna be a month
gonna be an interesting month a tough
month where hopefully we will see you
know my guess is that as some of these
red states Florida other places that are
being ravaged by exponentially growing
cases of the virus that are just having
a party they are likely going to have to
start and the question is will it be
soon enough will it be soon enough or
something to be able to be relaxed on
May first we just don't know it's it's
gonna be tough
we'll all be here and we're going to
wrap for today I appreciate everybody
who joined me remember on YouTube hit
that like and subscribe button although
on the way out sort of like a way to tip
us for the stream you hit like you hit
subscribe then you get the hell out of
here as many people are now doing
very very much appreciated we'll be back
tomorrow probably with another one one
of these streams plus our daily show and
everything else that we've been doing